hey everyone its rob and welcome to my
tutorial for the more gummy Christmas
tree that's a short clip from my
stop-motion animation video that I did
recently and you can check out the whole
thing by clicking on this link up here I
spent a couple of hours doing it but I
had a lot of fun so I hope that you
enjoy it
on my last update video I got numerous
requests the origami Christmas tree I
would have liked to get it out a little
bit earlier but it's still a fun model
to make anytime during the year
origami Valentine's Day tree you know
what I'm saying
it's a type of modular origami model
meaning it's made up of a whole bunch of
little pieces just like these you're
going to need three sheets of printer
paper I'm using two green and one orange
but if you have brown that will work
fine also once you have the paper you're
ready to go we're going to convert the
printer paper into five square sheets
just like these the two largest ones are
the same size so if you prefer to use
origami paper all you really need are
four different sizes from large to small
the orange sheet is going to make up the
base of the tree while the four other
green sheets are going to compose the
four top pieces of the tree
each of these are made the same exact
way the base is made slightly
differently now I'll show you what folds
you need to do in order to make the
proper sized squares grab a green and an
orange sheet and you're going to take
the upper right corner of the paper and
fold it across so that the top edge is
aligned with the left side edge here
once you neatly line up the edges you
can make a crease along the outside of
the paper do the same with the green
sheet grab the corner fold it to the
left and line up the top and the left
edges make a crease now all you need to
do is to remove this excess paper on the
bottom here by tearing it or cutting it
and when you do that you'll come up with
four sheets just like this you have two
of the larger squares and you also have
these two excess sheets so just grab the
green sheet take the top right corner
again and fold it across to the left so
that you line up the top and the left
edges make a crease and then all you
need to do is to remove this little
triangular area by taking off the excess
paper when you do that you'll come up
with your smallest piece now you have
the two largest squares and the smallest
square completed to make the last two
squares grab your last
sheet of green printer paper take the
top and fold it down to the bottom line
up the edges and then make a crease
along the top edge all you need to do
now is to rip the paper in half because
we only need half of the sheet once you
do that you'll get two sheets just like
this now just grab one of them because
you just need half and you're going to
do the same thing we've been doing take
the upper right corner fold it across to
the left and then you could remove the
excess paper so here I've already made
the creases so let's rip the paper and
then all you need to do so here you have
one square and you know what to do with
this excess sheet so just take the
corner fold it across and then remove
the excess paper on the bottom when
you're done you'll have five square
sheets just like the ones I showed now
I'm going to show you how to fold the
top four pieces of the tree which I made
the exact same way except they're
different sizes
grab your largest square we've already
folded it this way you want to take the
upper left corner now and fold it down
to the bottom right corner line up the
edges and make crease
unfold the paper and you'll see you have
an X in it take the top edge and fold it
down to the bottom edge and once they're
lined up make a crease when you unfold
it you'll see you now have a horizontal
line so we want to fold the left edge
over to the right edge now so if you do
want to flip it or turn it like this now
you could take the top and fold it down
to the bottom again make a crease now if
you unfold the paper you'll see you have
an X and also a cross in the paper turn
the paper like this and we're going to
fold the corner of the paper over to the
other corner on one of these diagonal
lines just like that so that we have a
triangle with the tip on the bottom hold
the paper and lift up the first layer
here and we're going to tuck this right
corner down towards the tip of the
triangle here
lift up the first layer and tuck this
corner inwards just like that then just
flatten everything out do the same with
the left side hold the paper here on the
right lift up this first layer tuck the
corner in and then flatten everything
out now we have this diamond structure
which is similar to the bird base we're
going to start making all of the pieces
of the origami tree with this diamond
even the base of the tree so you need to
remember how to make this what we're
going to do now is if you'll notice we
have four points here on the bottom now
we're going to take each one of those
points and fold them up to the top of
the diamond so start off with the one
here on the front grab this first layer
of paper and fold this point up to the
top like this once it's lined up make a
crease along the bottom now just flip
the paper over and do the same with this
point on the bottom take the corner fold
it up to the top and just make a crease
on the bottom
so now we just have two left now you'll
see its flattened out this way so what
you want to do is you want to hold it on
the side like this going to open these
two flaps on the front open the two
flaps on the back like this and then
flatten it out this way so just flatten
it this way now and now you'll see we
could just fold up these two points like
we did before so fold it up and make a
crease along the bottom flip it over and
do the same thing with the other side
now you should have something that looks
just like this okay so now that we have
each one of these four tips folded
upwards we're going to take each one and
we're going to pinch the two edges
together like this okay then what you
want to do is you want to fold it to the
right so that this edge here goes right
in this groove and the tip should align
with the right bottom corner here so
just take the tip fold it to the right
like this and then make a crease down
the middle so do that with the next one
pinch these two edges together probably
easier to set it down on the table pinch
the two edges together and then fold it
to the right just like this
fold the tip down to the right and then
crease on the center of it all the way
up to the middle of the model to make
sure everything is as flat as possible
do the same thing pinch the edges fold
it to the right and make a crease down
the middle do the same thing with the
last one just pinch the two edges
together and then fold that whole tip
down to the right just like that so now
your model should look something like
this if you take a look at the bottom of
the piece you'll see that we have four
flaps here and they're folded to the
right in a counterclockwise direction
that's not the way that we want them we
want them in a clockwise direction so
that we can tuck them into these little
grooves or slots so what you want to do
is to just flip over each one of these
little flaps to the left like that take
it and just flip it over like that
now you'll see you should be able to
take each one of these individual flaps
open up the center and you can tuck it
right into that slot like that take the
tip open up the paper and just fold it
right inside do the same with the rest
so just open up that little slot here
tuck it right into the center like that
now I'm not going to lie the last one is
pretty tricky so this is what you're
going to do I'm going to take it and
you're going to round it off to the left
like this
okay and at the same time you're going
to open this this slot here and push on
this edge so you want to push on this
edge like that take the tip round it off
like this and just roll it right into
there and make sure it's folding here on
this corner so you should be able to
kind of work it all the way in there and
push it in and then you'll see you want
to pop this back so just push here on
this edge now I know it's tricky but if
you practice it a little bit and make
sure that you're opening the paper
enough and rolling that in there you
should be able to get it okay so there
you go you have finished your piece now
that you know how to make one piece you
can go on to make the remaining top
pieces they do become a little bit
trickier as you go smaller and smaller
so if you're finding yourself getting
frustrated or having a little bit of
trouble don't worry about it all you
need to do is just make a couple of the
larger ones and your tree will still
come out looking pretty good however
you'll see that if you do practice a
little bit even with the smallest piece
you should be able to tuck everything in
and then finally get that last piece in
there
all that's left to do now is to fold the
base of the tree and as I said before
you're going to need one of these
diamond shapes for every single piece so
once you have one of these make sure
that you're holding the open end on the
bottom just like this with all of these
little tips facing down
then all we're going to do is take the
two top flaps and we're going to fold
these edges into the midline set it down
on the table take this top edge and fold
it in to the midline and make a crease
do the same with the other top flap take
this edge and fold it in you should have
something that looks just like this flip
it over and do the same with the other
two flaps just fold the right edge onto
the midline make a crease and do the
same with the left side from here on
you'll see that making the base is very
similar to making the green pieces the
only difference is that we don't fold
these little corners or tips all the way
up to the top what we're going to do
instead is just take the tip pull it
upwards until it can't go any more which
is basically along this edge and then
make a crease along the bottom flip it
over and do the same exact thing with
this tip just fold it up and then make a
crease on the bottom so now we're going
to do the same thing that we did before
turn it to the side open these front
flaps and open the back flaps and then
just squash it in this direction now now
you can take these two tips on the
bottom and fold it up all the way just
like this and make a crease
from here on making the base is exactly
the same as making the green pieces so
I'm going to speed up the video but I'll
still narrate and let you know what I'm
doing so we're going to pinch the tip
and fold it to the right and then crease
down the middle do the same thing for
the next one pinch the edges together
fold it to the right and then crease
down the middle do the same thing for
the last one
so now you have all these flaps and you
want to fold them to the left now so
that they're going in a clockwise
direction do that for all four of the
flaps and then you could tuck them in
one there's the second one
here's the third one and then the fourth
one that's a little tricky so just round
off the tip and roll it in there push on
that edge so that you open up the slot
and you should be able to kind of work
it in there so that it locks completely
and there you go there's your base now
that you've finished all the pieces just
grab the base and you'll see that these
four edges sticking up can fit into any
of the four slots on the bottom of the
pieces so all you need to do is to just
line them up and then you could slide it
in do the same with the next piece
and there you go there's your origami
tree I hope you enjoyed my tutorial for
the origami tree I know that on my other
video a lot of people also wanted to see
the interlocking single-sided
eight-pointed ninja star now if you
still want to see this let me know leave
me a comment below and also don't forget
to rate this video by giving it a thumbs
up and also subscribe by clicking the
button above thanks for watching guys
I'll see you soon